لم أقرأها حتى ذلك الحين
سألت بعد قراءة ذلك المئات من
انا اقرأ كتابا
أحدث الجامعات الإنجليزية التركية
لقد أنهيتُ مئات الكتب في ألمانيا
لقد قرأت كتاب الرواية الألمانية
وهلم جرا أو شيء من هذا القبيل
يكتب المسلمون في الدلافين غاري بك
إذا كنت مسلمًا من دينك ، فهذا شيء واحد
رائحة
[موسيقى]
لذلك ربما يكون هذا الشخص 13 الذي كنت تنتظره
قلت إنه لم يستطع العثور على شخص ، لكن في أعماقي ، هذا هو.
أنت تقول لم يحدث شيء جيد ، لا تكسرها
التي تعتقد أنها تمثل الإسلام
عمتي الحاج حجاب عمتي لهم
كما ترى وهم يرتكبون خطأ
اعتنق وارتكب خطأ فادحا في الإسلام
أنت تعلق
[موسيقى]
إما
قرأت أنني صدمت وها هو ملف
وهل هناك ضعف هنا؟ هل هو احتيال؟
ليس الأمر كما لو أنه سيحدث أيضًا لقراءة ميرال
بدأت
أجل
[موسيقى]
هذا هو نفس صديقي 2.50 رئيس
أخذها معًا لا يمكن إيقافها على هذا النحو
هذا صحيح شيء ما لك على مائدة العشاء.
أليس هذا قادمًا إذا قلت إنني سآتي
هذا ما درسته خارج الجامعة.
إذا قلت إنك كنت ولا تزال تعمل في الصناعة ، فهذا قادم
سأحترمه ولكني أفعله نفس الشيء و
هذه العقول المنخفضة تبدو جيدة أيضًا
كما كتبت ، سنرى ما يكتب.
يا إلهي ، كان هناك نساء يؤمنن
لا يعلم أنه يقول الآية
[موسيقى]
اشترك